what I've learned is
that little mapping out of more or less
what happens in the story really only
applies till the middle of the story I
don't want to know what's going to
happen in the second half I want to I I
know how I wear how I want to start it
off
Because by the time you get to the
middle of the story well now you know so
much more it's about character and the
dialogue just comes out of the character
and I don't lead the characters I let
the characters lead me I mean like for
instance if I've got a character here
with this glass and I have every
intention of getting him to where that
glass is they might reject the glass
right and they go somewhere else and
they are the ones that know best hope is
by
the 40 Mark or the 50 Mark that the
characters just take it from me and then
from that point on they're writing the
story wow